so let's talk about your general view of
what government ought to do
so what makes you a liberal in sort of
not the classical liberal sense
where we agree but the part where we
disagree what do you think government
ought to do well it should be as small
as possible
right i don't believe in massive
governments sprawling
government agencies with lots of people
doing jobs you're not quite sure what
they're doing soaking up public
expenditure
i think government should be responsible
it should take action
even if it's against the popular will
of the people you're made to be a
government
because people expect you to take
difficult decisions and to govern an
example i would use is someone like
margaret thatcher in in britain i would
compare her to the other female prime
minister about theresa may
margaret thatch was prepared to make
difficult tough decisions she was a
conservative
but theresa may wasn't she just wanted
to please everybody
i don't believe in people-pleasing
governments i believe you are elected
by the people you should live up as far
as possible to the manifesto that you
ran on
and i think trump to his credit has
basically delivered on most of the
things he said he would deliver on
and he certainly tried to you couldn't
argue that he's been elected in a
completely different thing
um so i think that that you know that's
a central part of government
is to do whatever the administration has
been elected has decided it wants to do
that's why they got elected
you know doing what the people have
elected you to do is important in
democracy
so i believe in that i don't believe in
a nanny state except to the point where
the public can sometimes be stupid too
stupid for his own good
you know do i think that government
should occasionally interfere
in the well-being of the people yes i do
actually
um so where do you draw the lines around
that what's the limiting principle when
it comes to
because people are very often quite
stupid
as it turns out and and you know that
and if you're on the right you think
that's the left and if you're on the
left you think that's the right but
the truth is that in personal habits
people make lots of mistakes make lots
of bad decisions
where do you draw the line around where
is the government's role in bettering
people's
lives because i think this is a
fundamental distinction between liberal
and conservatives take cigarette smoking
right most smokers knew it was bad for
them
right they know it's bad cigarette
smoking but they want the right to smoke
right
sort of constitutional right but they
want to have the right to smoke it's my
life
fine okay it's your life but actually
what has happened in countries like
britain and america in the last 20 years
is you don't now go into a bar and be
full of smoke if you don't want it to be
that to me seemed to be sensible
government you know yes you are
impinging on the right of a civilian
to lead the life they want to lead which
is to walk into a bar
and have a cigarette at the bar but
actually if most people in that bar
don't want to have a cigarette
why should they be subjected to
unhealthy
smoke from you in the way that they were
being
now is that nanny state by government to
ban
smoking from public places i would think
it was the right thing to do
i'm a non-smoker i spoke the odd cigar
but most smokers i know actually
shrugged their shoulders and kind of
accepted it
and there's a kind of template there i
would argue mr shapiro for the gun
debate
which we haven't had yet i'm sure we're
coming to which is
at what point does the safety and the
health
of a lot of people get dictated to
by a group of other people at what point
do you bring them together or what point
do you try and reach a consensus whether
smokers can still smoke
or they can still have a gun but
actually what they can't do is go into a
bar and shoot it up
and how do you stop them doing it it's a
fundamental question for the public
health of the country
and treating guns like a public health
issue would be a really smart move for
america right now
it might take the politics out of it
which has become so vicious and
polarizing
in glasgow and scotland had a huge
problem with knife crime a lot of knife
murders young kids
mainly white kids stabbing each other so
they treat it like a public health
debate and they've massively reduced
knife crime
in scotland which has been great so you
know
nanny state to a point i believe in
people's fundamental freedoms
but the cigarette debate to me was an
interesting one you know drink driving
was an interesting debate in america
wasn't it
you go about 50 years you could you get
in your car and have a few drinks and
drive around
and then mothers against drink driving
mad i think they were called
rose up after a particularly heinous
drink driving
incident and they affected real change
and now you can't do that
um now there will be people who still
think i wanna have a few beers and have
a drive okay but you can't
actually because you might kill people
and
they have as much right to not be killed
as you do to get in your car with a few
drinks
it's fascinating to go a little bit
beneath the surface on this debate
because i think that
the debate here is really about
externalities
meaning that the reason that we have
laws about not smoking in public places
and there you'd have to distinguish for
me
even between public parks which are run
by the government
and public establishments which run by
private business owners so in my view
the government actually shouldn't be
involved in that if a private business
owner wants to have a successful
business
they will stop people from smoking in
their business in most cases because
they're going to lose business because
most people don't smoke
and it's annoying to have people smoke
there but but take the drunk driving
example it's a better example so the
drunk driving
obviously there are obvious
externalities to people weaving all over
the road and the way you actually police
drunk driving
is by pulling somebody over who is
weaving all over the road and driving
recklessly so
you could theoretically have a crime
defined as reckless driving
without the actual drink being a part of
it per se because you know
you if you drink in your home
fundamentally and again this comes back
to the guns debate for me
right fundamentally you want to stop
people getting in their car drunk
that's really what you want you want to
affect a cultural change in thinking
and the undeniable reality is that a far
smaller percentage of americans now get
into a car
under the influence of alcohol than used
to
because of the effect of that
campaigning and most americans accept
that
america you've got to remember one of my
sort of
strange things about the gun debate was
that america's probably the one of the
most regulated countries on earth
in so many ways if i want to buy a car i
couldn't believe the amount of
paperwork i had to do i wanted to buy a
pet dog
my god i mean you're there all day you
know in other words you know my
my 21 it's now 26 but my 21 year old son
at the time
six foot two inch long hair and a beard
with his mate it's the same
took them to gladstones in malibu for a
lunch
and they wanted a non-alcoholic beer
and they got refused because they didn't
have their id on them
a non-alcoholic beer because it has
0.001
alcohol in it i didn't even know that
and when i asked them to explain why
they went yeah i'm afraid that's the
problem they
they can't prove they're 21 and you have
to be 21 even of a non-alcoholic beer
the same month up in arizona an
eight-year-old girl
went to a bullets and burgers had her
burger
then went to the range was handed by a
former marine
a load of firearms loaded
fired them eventually got handed an uzi
submachine gun
fired two bullets and lost control and
shot the instructor
in the head and killed him a terrible
tragedy
she will never get over that i'm sure
her parents were videoing it on their
phone
and you see them suddenly lose control
of the phone they won't get over it
the guy's dead his family won't get over
it what i won't get over is the
extraordinary disparity
between this draconian ruling of my son
age
22 to have a non-alcoholic beer
in la and this eight-year-old girl i
have a seven-year-old girl now
an eight-year-old girl being able to
fire an uzi machine gun
submachine gun loaded at a gun range and
that remains legal
because it's her constitutional right to
do that that's where i have a problem
it's more the disparity of the way that
america regulates these things
well i think that the the real question
there is criminalizing recklessness
meaning that it's a weird thing to
criminalize a 21 year old drinking
a non-alcoholic beer right and in the
other case
obviously i would think that it should
be criminal recklessness to hand an
eight-year-old girl a gun she's not
capable of controlling
and that would be chargeable in my view
you know just under
probably basic negligence but it was i
mean i don't know a particular case but
in my view that should be although not
necessarily as an effect of
banning guns per se because as we've
discussed now several times
i think that the the countervailing view
is that there are lots of law-abiding
citizens
who do want to be able to own a gun and
should be able to own a gun i understand
why americans want to defend themselves
in a country with 330 million guns i
understand why americans i've heard bill
maher say
he has a gun right because he knows he
has threats and he knows that
they may come with guns the countries
are washed with guns
what i don't get and this is the same
debate we had before but let me make it
probably a simpler debate
for the purposes of this which is there
has been an
undeniable increase in the number of
massacres i'm not talking about
shootings of two three people
mass shootings on a grandiose horrific
scale
in the last 20 years they are
accelerating
for whatever reason and the fire power
that's being used
is ferocious
the guy in date in ohio recently
he was shot dead within 24 seconds of
firing
his first bullet but because he had an
ak-47 he's able to get off i think 41
rounds
and hit 26 people maybe more i think
nine
died and at that point i'm like
okay surely surely
if you're concerned about gun safety
and you fundamentally believe in the
principle of regulation you could have
it in every other part of your life
right you have in every part of your
life you also accept i presume
machine guns are bad right automatic
weapons right so you've accepted
regulation on guns
so i say well why can't you go a step
further now except that the preferred
weapon of choice of almost
every one of these massacre shooters
they all use
these rifles but that is the
countervailing question is whether what
we are actually doing here
is reverse engineering the regulation by
focusing in on the mass shootings
meaning that
every year in the united states
approximately 400 people are killed with
rifles approximately 600 people are
killed with knives
about 30 000 people die of handgun
wounds
many of those are suicides so are we
focusing in
on the mass shootings because we are
focusing on the rifles or are we
focusing on the rifles because we are
focusing in on the mass shootings why
not why not just go for a full gun ban
in other words so
i don't propose a gun bat i accept there
are too many guns in circulation
it's not like australia where they after
the hobart massacre in the mid 90s
they banned almost all guns from
civilians even then only one third of
guns were turned in in the australian
gun buyback and
that's a lot of guns it's certainly a
lot of guns the equivalent here would be
a 110
million guns 100 i mean the murder rate
in america went down faster after the
hobart
i know we'll remember and our gun supply
increases you and i
we can argue the details we can do a
whole other hour about this there's a
bigger thing which is a
cultural response to these kind of
massacres i found it extraordinary
that after sandy hook when 20 young
first graders are literally
blown to pieces in their classroom that
america the number one superpower in the
world
was incapable of coming together and
finding a unified response
to try and prevent that happening again
of any kind
in britain we had a direct equivalent of
dumb lane in scotland
but there was an a cultural reaction
from britain from left and right was
never political at all
that after 16 children were killed in
dunblane and scotland in a similar
attack by a lone gunman that something
fundamentally had to change
and we were very draconian as you know
we banned almost all guns from civilian
circulation interesting thing happened
for five years
gun crime ticked up a bit actually and
then they said okay we need to make it
more punitive
so that's a five-year mandatory prison
sentence if you're caught with one of
these guns
and ever since that moment gun crime has
gone down
we have other issues in britain like
knife crime very serious problems of
knife crime
and the reaction from the british is the
same we've got to stop this
what can we do let's limit the amount of
knives let's make it draconian to carry
an eye for the three
in other words our reaction to knife
crime epidemic now
is the same as our reaction to gun crime
which is we can't allow this to continue
let's bring in laws to change it and
it's not left and right arguing about
it the three things i've always tried to
campaign for here
universal background checks i don't
think you're against that
not in concept although if it does end
with a massive government gun registry i
have a problem right and i understand
why because that comes back to the
threat of tyranny and everything else
right
i get that but i've always campaigned
for that i think there should be a limit
on all magazines of 10 bullets
i don't understand why anyone would need
more you don't need it for hunting
you don't have a sports shooting you can
do that within britain if you want a
sports shoe you have a license
why can't you have that here and thirdly
i don't see a need
a need in the same way that only the
only
possible need for a machine gun is to
kill lots of people very quickly
i think that has now become the
preferred way of using one of these
assault rifles
and i don't understand why the argument
against machine guns is
this and the argument against these
assault rifles is a different argument
to me it's the same thing you're just
extending
you're extending common sense so are you
talking about a ban on the sale of
of ars and and so-called assault rifles
which are really also my autos are you
talking about a full confiscation is
there a hundred million of those in
circulation i think you would you would
try and do what they did in australia
you would have a
buy-back you know you'd say look we are
going to try i know
i know good luck because at the moment
people are so entrenched about this
driven by
political partisan debate but actually i
would i would appeal to the company
because you're talking about
confiscating 100 million guns on the
basis of 400 yearly deaths not
confiscating asking people to give them
up well i mean unless you're going to
punish them and you're going to pay them
you're going to pay them unless you
you're going to pay three times what
they're going and okay it is
okay nobody's going to turn that in but
you have to do something is my point
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
leftist tear gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button